[Music]
what's going on everybody Ian Hardis
here on behalf of PFF welcome to BR
fantasy got a lot of great things to
talk about today but first we're going
to break down that trade that took over
a regular Thursday afternoon like the
NFL has a tendency to do Kadarius Tony
sideline no more has been traded to the
Kansas City Chiefs for a conditional
third round pick as well as a six
rounder not exactly a fire sale type of
situation the Chiefs had to go out of
their way to be able to bring Tony to
town and if you're like me and you
drafted a little bit too much because
there's Tony back in August this was the
best case possible scenario this was
always something where time and time
again week after week having to look at
that zero on the bench out with the
hamstring injury was not easy but what
kept us there what kept Him on a lot of
benches it's that raw talent that He
flashed not just in the Cowboys game
last year okay that's kind of one of the
misconceptions about Tony the Saints
game before the Cowboys game was
actually his first real flashy
performance even after the Cowboys game
unfortunately got hurt against the Rams
but he was on his way to a huge game but
before that so with Tony when you add it
all up was 11th in yards per out run
eighth and yards after the catch per
reception last season bigger sample size
than you think he actually was able to
just about get to 50 targets and again
was playing some great football before
unfortunately he was too injured to get
back and I know I know he's always
injured it's happened to Florida until
his senior year and then he led the team
in receiving last year he gets going
he's banged up and we haven't even heard
from him basically for months with this
season it looks like he is just fine
everybody he's pulling the you know I
believe Rick Nash move in the wheelchair
all of a sudden sits up and there are no
problems at all he actually deleted this
tweet but if you happen to see it before
Tony himself actually tweeted that joke
would have been funny if I was actually
hurt still LOL irrelevant people don't
get updates so seemingly the whole
hamstring injury was just a cover for
the Giants not being pleased with enough
with Tony to make him active on game
days so wicked air is Tony in Kansas
City he's got to stay healthy and this
is not a given and he's got to go start
but again a third and a six round pick
this does have all sorts of promise and
God forbid he still is available on your
way for wire go get Kadarius Tony right
now it's worst news for Miko Hardman
fresh off that three touchdown game as
well as Sky Moore and also small
downgrades for Juju Smith Schuster and
mvs again we are adding a really
talented wide receiver to the mix here
luckily we got Patrick Mahomes to just
help keep everyone happy everyone
involved and just keep putting up big
points last week really was the first
time all season now we saw these wide
receivers all collectively boom in the
same game 75 combined PPR points from
Miko mvs Juju Justin Watson had a
touchdown out there as well before that
hadn't even cracked 40. so cadarius Tony
on the Chiefs best case possible landing
spot good for Juan Dale Robinson back as
well in New York overall just another
trade that's again been making the NFL
more fun than ever even during
the dark days of the week all right
everyone welcome to be our Fantasy Live
presented by State Farm today's agenda I
got five starts and five sets that are
all based upon their specific matchups
for this week so I want to start off by
saying this is not an end-all be-all I'm
gonna talk about sitting certain guys
that are still going to be ranked inside
my top 24 top 25 if you have someone
that's you know a wide receiver 50 or a
wide receiver 60 out there no please
don't sit them just because of that but
I'm going to talk about the players
around them and some of the surprising
factors that might cause you to actually
give them a set and a close start set
decision so with that said let's get
started with Rashad Bateman playing on
Thursday Night Football here against the
Buccaneers secondary that is all kinds
of banged up right now a full health
Tampa Bay Buccaneers defense can play
with just about anyone but that is not
the case right now one starting safety
Logan Ryan he's been on IR with a foot
injury another starting safety Antoine
Winfield he is out with a concussion
number one quarterback Carlton Davis he
is out with a hip injury even Sean
Murphy bunting is also going to to be
missing this one with the quad injury
now Bateman himself not exactly at 100
he is dealing with a foot injury but
it's the same injury that he missed time
with before which I know doesn't
necessarily make you feel better but it
seems to be more of a maintenance thing
that's my big Point here he practiced in
full on Wednesday we've already gotten a
report saying that the Ravens are
hopeful both Bateman and Andrews are out
there and this is a spot for him so last
week I know he only had four cats for 42
yards he got stopped at the one inch
line almost had you know a touchdown
tallied onto that total the volume
hasn't quite been there but what could
bring that volume having this sort of
secondary
being such a big Advantage for this
Ravens passing attack that has hit a bit
of a slide but again I really think
tonight is this uh Thursday night get
right spot so you guys can probably
guess where I'm going with this one
right now I will be starting absolutely
starting Rashad Bateman this week he is
my wide receiver 30 ahead of guys like
Jerry Judy Juan Dale Robinson Drake
London and Romeo Dobbs I think it's a
situation where we see the Ravens Force
to push push their foot on the gas just
a little bit more than usual Bateman is
someone that hey don't remember those
big play touchdowns he was ripping off
the first couple weeks of the year that
guy still very much still there and
someone we shouldn't ignore in fantasy
lineups from RC Italy Jamar Chase owners
how you feeling I just tweeted out the
uh that 70 show kitty Jeff I've heard
just like pouring the tequila sadly
shaking her head that's how I'm feeling
it's freaking terrible guys my home
League I know we don't care about it but
you know have Jamar Chase there so I am
with you God forbid Tyler Boyd is out
there on the way to wires I think he's
going to be the big time winner of this
uh Arrangement obviously T Higgins but
obviously T Higgins is a happily owned
already everywhere so with Tyler Boyd I
would point out he's actually played now
if you include Joe Burroughs rookie
season
where obviously Chase was still not in
the NFL yet uh Boyd has now actually had
12 total games with one of T Higgins or
jamarche sideline he's put up big time
numbers guys if you just take his per
game averages and put it across 17 games
112 catches 1173 yards and six and a
half touchdowns so Mike Thomas the other
Mike Thomas should be sliding into three
wide receiver sets because the pengals
won't bring back my guy odd and Tate I
don't think he's going to be as much of
a factor the big beneficiaries Tyler boy
T Higgins and even their tight end
Hayden Hurst from Kiana Merritt is
Michael Pittman Jr still a threat with
Sam Ellinger now at QB I'm tentatively
giving Michael Pittman the benefit of
Doubt for a week this is the NFL's third
most pass happy offense so I'm having a
big feeling they're gonna be more so the
bottom three passing offense with Sam
Ellinger under Center the Big Time
downgrades premiere Alec Pierce and
Paris Campbell I don't think there's
gonna be enough volume to go around the
entire offense fingers crossed the Colts
still view Michael Pittman as their
Alpha clear-cut number one wide receiver
that has really been for the better part
of the last three seasons
all right next one everyone mentioned
him in the lead up to the show but
Brandon Cooks is an interesting spot
this week on the one hand he is on the
trade block and we have seen guys on the
trade block get showcased in the past
you know just force feeding him targets
look how good this guy still is everyone
then they go trade him on the other hand
look what happened with James Robinson
last week he was obviously going to the
Jets and what happened they put him out
there for five ten snaps I don't think
that James Robinson's performance
getting benched by Travis etm was
exactly what made the Jets go out and
get him it was more so a situation of
them not wanting to damage their trade
asset that they're about to trot out
there so with that in mind I'm not
thinking of the trade situation as a
positive for Brandon Cooks and this
matchup just isn't going to be good for
him Titans cornerback Christian with a K
Fulton has been doing some really good
things and Shadow coverage specifically
against Brandon Cooks held him to just
two catches for 18 scoreless yards in
their matchup last season and this
season he's at least been able to limit
some really good wide receivers Terry
McLaurin five catches 76 yards Michael
Pittman six catches 58 yards decent
enough games but let's face it those
offenses as bad as you know they can be
at times as well a little bit higher
upside than what we see in Houston where
if your name's not Damien Pierce you're
not getting to touch the football all
that often just 6.25 targets per game
for Brandon Cooks this year I just don't
think that this is a situation we really
want to take advantage of when you do
look at the total fantasy points the
Titans have allowed to wide receivers
they do rank 30th but a lot of that is
just when the bills went absolutely Ham
on them all the way back in week two so
with all that in mind Brandon Cooks will
be a sit for me
behind Brent now behind quoting son
behind Jacoby Myers guys I would
confidently play ahead of Brandon Cooks
moving right along with someone I just
mentioned Terry McLaren and it's it's
actually a nice coincidence I said he
had 75 yards or whatever no wide
receiver in the NFL has a objectively
prettier like more aesthetically
pleasing 70 yard caves than Terry
mclareness what he's got to work with in
Washington he's always getting the
opponent's number one cornerback hell I
mean jair Alexander Packer's number one
corner he had not shadowed since week
seven 2020 before tracking Terry
McLaurin last week that's how much NFL
defenses respect this guy and I think
that they're going to continue to do
that this time with Ace Colts cornerback
Stefan Gilmore really the only true
bright spot from this Colts team this
entire season I mean the things he's
been able to do in his one-on-one
matchups yeah Brandon Cook's got 82
yards speaking of uh and week one
against them a lot of that did come on a
fleet flicker that was not in Gilmore's
coverage though Marvin Jones got shut
down Courtland Sutton did not have a
good game you guys remember that game
winning pbu that's Gilmore actually had
right in direct coverage over Sutton
then last week yeah he got put on Nick
Westbrook bikini who Goose egged
accordingly so again Terry McLaren we
just saw him beat up a great corner I
know he can do it you know when the
situation is right that said the Taylor
heinecke roller coaster I think we saw a
better version last week than we
necessarily should expect every single
week moving forward so again expecting
India to slow things down a little bit
of Sam Ellen Show under Center all that
said I will be sitting
but this is what I was talking about
earlier in terms of it's all relative to
what's going on so Terry should still be
in your top 24 wide receivers however I
would start guys like Gabriel Davis
Tyler Lockett even Michael Pittman and
Chris olave well ahead of Terry
hopefully they can just get some
stabilization under Center in Washington
if it's heineckey if it's Sam Howell
returning Carson Wentz we'll take anyone
because Tara McLaren is far too good in
real life to be such an inconsistent
fantasy performer sometimes from CJ
Gomez Chris Godwin or Gabriel Davis oh
man you guys asked me some tough
questions sometimes I appreciate it
though you know that's part of the job
I'm gonna lean towards Chris Godwin
right here he's out there without
Russell Gage uh this week out with that
hamstring injury and when you look at
the way the Buccaneers have been playing
on offense Gage really was kind of their
insurance policy on Goblin he's the
other guy working in those shallow
intermediate areas of the field so you
take away Gage guys I would not be
surprised at all if we start seeing some
of those 10 12 catch games that Goblin
has had so I would say full PPR
definitely Goblin if you are in standard
that's when I go with someone like
Gabriel Davis but fantastic problem to
have man you better have another two or
three top 12 wide receivers on that
Squad of yours good job by you from
these ambro Gus Edwards or Brandon ayok
if Debo Samuel misses this game with a
hamstring injury which is not looking
good he hasn't practiced all week give
me Brandon I the only problem with Gus
Edwards guys he got the two touchdowns
last week still very much a three back
committee it was Gus Edwards Justice
Hill and even Kenyan Drake Still finding
a way flirting with that 10 total touch
marks so there's going to be games where
Gus Edwards is going to fall into the
end zone a couple times that said let's
not too overreact he still doesn't catch
passes and again but the Baltimore
Ravens will continue to use not one not
two but three running backs in this
offense
next up the Carolina Panthers wide
receiver finally getting back on track a
little bit DJ Moore PPR wide receiver
nine last week and that still takes him
up to just the wide receiver 37 on the
season how far some of our Kings have
fallen but hey here's the thing that did
come coincidentally or not so
coincidentally without Robbie Anderson
without Christian McCaffrey all of a
sudden this is an offense with no one
else to throw the ball to except DJ
Moore out there and hey PJ Walker was
slinging that thing pretty well last
week so I think the volume part is the
big thing A lot of people are missing I
mean Robbie Anderson you can think he
sucks that's fine he out targeted DJ
Moore as recently as 2020 in this
offense they have not been afraid to use
him right there alongside DJ Moore
really over the better part of the past
three years so you take him out of the
picture and you take Target hog
Christian McCaffrey out of the picture
all of a sudden I think DJ more 10 plus
targets per week should be not only an
expectation but something where if the
Panthers don't do it uh they should be
sued for malpractice so the bigger thing
too we have the volume and what else
we're looking for that sweet sweet
matchup Falcons secondary dead last in
PPR points per game allowed to wide
receivers this season they have been bad
and they have been bad when they were
healthy AJ Terrell before he got injured
League High seven touchdowns allowed in
his coverage
I don't want to hate on AJ Terrell too
much because he actually has been
following the number one wide receivers
this year last year stayed on his side
of the field and yeah they usually
didn't throw the ball his way this year
he actually has been going out of his
way track that number one the problem is
he's not gonna be doing that this week
because he's suffered a hamstring injury
expected to keep him out and oh yeah we
also have safety Jalen Hawkins dealing
with a concussion he didn't practice
quarterback Casey Hayward already on IR
with a shoulder injury maybe they get D
Alfred back but guys come on we just
talked about three significant secondary
pieces from an already bad defense that
are not going to be there in this one so
with all that said I will be going back
to the well it's scary but I am starting
DJ Moore once again this week ahead of
guys like Jacoby Myers Deontay Johnson
and Jerry Judy it's a gross offense I
get that but it's illegal for wide
receivers and gross offense and still
put up some good numbers when they have
that sweet sweet volume and hopefully a
good matchup to go with it
from Ryan underscore beverage start one
Michael Thomas Christian Kirk Drake
London bro I don't know if Michael
Thomas is going to play ever again
hopefully I'm just you know he's not
practicing with the foot injury it's
been so long so definitely not Michael
Thomas I gotta go with Christian Kirk
fun stat I found uh this week this
Falcons offense I have to fully hate on
it because they're still top 12 in
scoring top 12 in EPA per play and stuff
but this is the most run-heavy offense
since the 2009 Rex Ryan LED New York
Jets that's what we're seeing going on
in Atlanta right now and hey Tyler
Alexander and Caleb Huntley getting like
30 combined touches per game I don't
know how it works I don't expect it to
keep working it is and even in a game
last week where they were trailing
almost the entire time Marcus Marietta
just 14 pass attempts so love love love
the long-term upside Drake London for
now though give me Christian Kirk
from at e for ranch I started Adam
thielen or Jamal Williams at the flex
it's going to be Adam thielen if DeAndre
Swift is back which I think he will be
for a change DeAndre Swift did practice
in full to start the week so the problem
is too with Jamal Williams honestly it's
really close even if Swift is out again
because Jamal Williams isn't getting a
three down role without DeAndre Swift in
the picture like we thought he might
unfortunately Craig Reynolds and Justin
Jackson are coming in taking a lot of
that pass down work so Jamal Williams
still very much someone that when the
lions are scoring touchdowns he's the
best bet to be that guy on the goal line
getting in there unfortunately fumble
won last weekend hey number one ranked
scoring offense through five weeks was
the Detroit Lions over their last uh
eight quarters of football six total
points how the mighty have fallen maybe
that Roar will get restored so far not
so much all right guys yeah running back
here talking about David Montgomery this
Bears offense actually been doing some
pretty good things recently Justin
Fields with three straight qb1 finishes
but the backfield has been the
Intriguing part because Montgomery when
you just look at his snap abstinence
total touches per game he profiles
that's someone that should be in Far
More fantasy football lineups than not
promise Khalil Herbert just keeps on
coming this year yards per carry 6.2
versus four in favor of Herbert yards
after contact PFF Russian grade all
these things are in favor favor of
Herbert and my first thought was okay
Herbert a little bit more of a slasher
potentially maybe he's getting just more
friendly you know plays Aaron Jones and
AJ Dylan as Zeke and Tony Pollard ask as
fun as it is to look at the
backup running backs averaging the god
of yards per carry I just wanted to make
sure we were checking all the boxes
Herbert actually has based eight plus
defenders in the Box on 53 percent of
his carries whereas Montgomery is only
at 39 so if anything Montgomery has been
the one set up a little bit more for
Success against lighter boxes just
hasn't been able to still equal what
Herbert's doing I don't think Montgomery
is going to get completely overtaken he
is better than Herbert overall in terms
of yards per outrun the receiving game
in terms of his PFF past blocking grade
but guys the bigger issues here are the
matchup the Bears are implied to score a
weak low 16.5 points by that all I mean
is if you take the spread of every game
with the game total you know you can
pretty much get the final score that
Vegas is implying so Bears all the way
down there at just 16.5 Cowboys defense
they've allowed the fourth fourth fewest
PPR points per game two opposing
backfields I gotta be sitting David
I would take Gus Edwards Naji Harris
whoever ends up starting for the
Cardinals and even Raheem moster over
David Montgomery this week from Charles
billovic is Miles Sanders now a must
start match-up proof RB he's pretty
close so here's the thing he's not going
to catch many passes this is the
League's fifth most run heavy offense
and dual threat quarterbacks like Jalen
hurts they usually scramble instead of
checking the ball down but this offense
has been so good fourth ranked scoring
offense that we're still getting a lot
of touchdown opportunities so Jalen
hurts leads the NFL and Carries inside
the five yard line but Eagles running
backs as a whole are actually still a
top 10 unit in terms of rushes inside
the 10-yard line now if we do look at
inside the five yard line closer to the
goal line they drop to 16th but it's not
as bad as situations that we've seen
like Josh Allen with the bills before
and you know Lamar Jackson with the
Ravens where it just hasn't been quite
as easy for their running backs to put
up some big numbers Kenneth gamewell
takeover doesn't seem imminent at all
Boston Scott's been banged up not much
of a factor miles Sanders Rock Solid rb2
now and moving forward
from Jordan wedding DeAndre Hopkins or
Chris olave ideally both I am going to
get the nod to DeAndre Hopkins it's so
funny how the entire off-season
discourse is like oh he's washed he
needed the Peds to be good and then one
game 60 minutes later he's back to being
pretty much a consensus top 10 wide
receiver so right now DeAndre Hopkins I
mean those 14 targets he had last week
the most he's had in a game since his
actual Cardinals debut I do think he's
just such a Target volume hog but you
better have a really good roster to be
even considering sitting Chris olave
apparently you do if this is the
question but Speaking of Chris olave I
mean what a hot stretch he's been on PPR
wide receiver 17 wide receiver 18 and
wide receiver 13 over these past three
games even with Andy Dalton under Center
I thought that this drop-off could
actually be bad for Chris olave because
he's had such a ridiculous average
Target death this year
17.4 yards that's the second highest
Mark in the league and I do kind of
believe in the idea that wide receivers
earn their target death based on what
they're able to do great and Chris olave
lest we forget all all-time leader in
receiving touchdowns at the Ohio State
University he's been able to get it done
all over the field regardless of the
quarterback all season long so
Michael Thomas foot injury Jarvis Landry
ankle injury they're out of the picture
guess what's not changing Chris olave as
the Undisputed wide receiver one in this
offense facing a Raiders D that yeah we
got Max Crosby we got some good talent
on that front seven but specifically on
uh targets two wide receivers this year
has not been that good explosive pass
play rate passing yards per attempt
passer rating allowed all bottom six
marks from this Raiders secondary so I
really do think that a Lobby is emerging
as a dark horse Rookie of the Year
candidate top 10 in the league and and
just total receiving yards right now and
that's with him having to miss a good
half of a game due to that concussion so
with all that said guys I will unless
you got DeAndre Hopkins on the squad
beat starting Chris a Lobby this week
give me a Lobby ahead of guys like Terry
McLaurin Devonte Smith Amari Cooper
among others from T Myers shy Flex
Damien Pierce or Chris Godwin Damien
Pierce got to be every single start but
this is man I wish I could look at your
roster because the answer should be both
get them both in your lineup Chris
Goblin is going to be someone that again
I think is going to see far better days
ahead but there's not much going on in
Houston I mean literally
think about the last three years of
Houston Texans football can you name one
good thing that's happened other than
Damien Pierce just doing Damien Pierce
things I feel like every single Lovie
Smith press conference it doesn't matter
what the question is it's just hey let's
get Damien Pierce 20 touches this week
and they do it so this fantasy manager
should be awfully Happy from at Mark
Landsberg what do you trade away Tua and
Tyrique for Hertz and Hopkins
yeah I think I would I'm far more
confident it hurts as the fantasy
quarterback versus Tua and I don't think
the drop off from Tyrique to Hopkins is
that big look at the fantasy ranks
around the industry this week and again
it's this week moving forward both
Tyrique and DeAndre Hopkins are going to
be top 10 wide receivers so two uh yeah
you know it's a situation where he's got
better games than he did last Sunday
night where the Steelers drop not one
not two not three four separate
interceptions I just think that again
that boom from two of the jalenhurst
gives you such a great Edge uh compared
to again that more minor drop-off from
Tyrique to DeAndre Hopkins
all right guys another running back
loaded afce score I want to talk a
little about Devin Singletary it's been
up and down for him this year we've seen
some really good weeks in some not so
good weeks a lot of it has been based on
their ability to just be in a game for a
little bit longer than we'd be expecting
so overall they've had three games the
bills have won by 21 or more points and
his snap rates in those games 59 54 and
54 now they've also had three games
decided by four points or fewer in those
games 73 88 and 86 percent snap rates
the other thing because I understand
they are 10 point plus home favorites
against the Green Bay Packers here on
Sunday night the one thing that really
helps me believe that Devin Singletary
is gonna be able to Boom even if the
bills run away with this one is the fact
that Zack Moss before their buy was a
healthy scratch for the first time all
season long so they're really just
rolling out with Devin Singletary and
James Cook by the way don't be afraid if
you have the roster space just to get
James Cook may be there for a week we've
seen this in the past DeAndre Swift was
a good notable example where we have the
rookie running back not playing much all
of a sudden you have the extra bye week
to get them you know more into the game
plan and they start to have a bigger
roll ahead so
if we end up having this again just a
two RB backfield with singletarian cook
we can live with that in the year 2022
only so many workhorses left and God
forbid Aaron Rodgers and Company find a
way to keep this one close I do think we
can see Singletary flirting with that 20
touch Mark that is not always there so
again Packers 24th and PPR points per
game allowed to are B uh difference
making Edge Rashaan Gary started off the
week with the concussion and not
practicing so with all that said
everyone I will be starting Devin
Singletary this Sunday night ahead of
the Bears RBS Daryl Henderson Naji
Harris Gus Edwards and more from mofa
shy Flex Elijah Moore or Isaiah McKenzie
we're gonna have to drink the Kool-Aid
here and go back to Elijah Moore it's a
tough question unfortunately before that
Chiefs buy we saw just a rough game from
Isaiah McKenzie dropped a touchdown from
Josh Allen had another drop out there
and accordingly the bills were willing
to not give him the full time slot role
we actually saw Isaiah McKenzie losing a
lot of reps to their rookie Khalil
Shakur who on the other hand continues
to make the most out of each and every
opportunity so I thought when Crowder
went down we were going to see a lot
more McKenzie just hasn't quite been the
case give me Elijah Moore as gross as
his Jets offense has been
from Gardner for God Rondell Moore or
Romeo Dobbs that is going to be a close
one let me go to my handy dandy ranks
here I do have Romeo Dobbs just a little
bit ahead we could see a lot more Robbie
Anderson this weekend I just want to see
a game where DeAndre Hopkins is there
and Kyla Murray looks anywhere else only
two Targets for Rondell Moore last week
Kyla really didn't look his way again
after that offensive pass interference
slash dropped that could have should
have would have been a 10-yard touchdown
in the end zone so Rondo more
unfortunately it looks like calamari is
more than happy to just featured DeAndre
Hopkins ahead of everyone else I will be
calling it Romeo Dobbs especially with
al-mazard expected to now miss this game
with a shoulder injury
all right guys running back right now
starting for the Los Angeles Rams how
quickly things change in that backfield
cam maker status still uncertain so
Daryl Henderson first game this year
without Cam makers 70 snaps 12 carries
and three targets however not the only
back not the only running back here to
worry about Malcolm Brown did get a
quarter of the snaps himself seven
carries and one target no Kyron Williams
yet the Notre Dame rookie is still on ir
and he's Sean McBay has already
clarified he's not gonna be back this
week but the one thing about the Rams
guys and it's not necessarily going to
happen this week it is Thursday after
all one of the reports that came out
from that Christian McCaffrey the 49ers
trade was the fact the Rams were also a
Suitor that was heavily involved in that
deal so we talk about guys like Kareem
hunt like the earnest Johnson some of
these running backs that are on the
Block I do wonder how much longer Daryl
Henderson is going to have this two like
pretty close to a three down rule so if
you do have Daryl Henderson some of your
league mates think that hey this is
gonna be a rest of the season rb2 I
would not be afraid to sell high on him
at all but the bigger problem here is
just that I'm not even sure he's going
to have that could have a game this week
even if he is the future running back
we have four straight games now of the
San Francisco 49ers shutting down this
offense again they had the two games
last year and then the NFC championship
in one game this year the Rams Total
Team rushing yards in those games 57 70
64 and 52. just brutal I believe that uh
you know Sean McVeigh smart guy he knows
that trying to attack Nick Bosa and Fred
Warner in that nasty front seven isn't
his path to Victory is trying to throw
the ball all over the yard so that'd be
great if Daryl Henderson was more
involved in the passing game we'll take
targets over carries all day long the
problem is the Rams are tied for the six
fewest targets two running backs this
season so top five defense and PPR
points per game against running backs
top eight in yards before contact for
Carrie even though I think Daryl
Henderson will have a good enough role
for another week I will be setting him
just my rb-22 right there with Naji
Harrison that does not feel good to be
right there next to Naji Harris right
now got a quarterback for you guys
Trevor Lawrence Loki the quarterback
nine this season in Fantasyland qv4 and
qb9 finishes over the last two weeks so
if you only looked at that didn't get a
chance to watch the games you'd be
pretty happy about it I think it's
unsustainable guys three rushing
touchdowns over the past two weeks all
on goal line QB sneaks he's been on his
jail and hurts early and often and
unfortunately this week
he's in London first of all we have a
London game so Broncos Jaguars players 9
30 a.m Eastern on Sunday morning don't
be the person that you know sleeps into
11 and misses you know the last second
start sit and then you got to blame it
so I'm telling you right now London game
9 30 Broncos Jaguars get them in or out
of your lineups and then you can go back
to sleep again but really against this
Broncos team yeah Russell Wilson and the
offensive struggles have taken the big
story lines why wouldn't they they are
Ted last in scoring this year I still
can't believe it this is pff's highest
grade overall defense in terms of
overall team coverage grade and they
have been fantastic against opposing
passing attacks all season long only
10.3 fantasy points per game allowed to
oppose in quarterbacks easily the lowest
Mark in the entire league they haven't
even allowed 225 passing yards in a game
so I get it Justin feels like you don't
need to necessarily throw the ball all
that well to be a great quarterback and
Trevor Lawrence does have those rushing
touchdowns recently
problem guys only 3.7 carries per game
this year Trevor Lawrence can run I'm a
big Ohio State Homer I still have
nightmares about that dude running 60
yards through the heart of that defense
back in 2019 but the Jaguars are not
asking him to run enough to make up for
this again brutal matchup so I'm gonna
tell you guys to sit Trevor Lawrence
and then you get to sleep in and not
have to worry about Trevor Lawrence you
know bombing against the Broncos over
there in London so I would start Derek
Carr Daniel Jones and Geno Smith all
over Trevor Lawrence this week one more
running back for you all Miami Dolphins
lead running back Raheem moster he did
pop up on the injury report with a
limited practice here on Thursday I'm
not overly worried this happened a
couple weeks ago where he came into the
game pretty questionable and we didn't
see his workload really change over
these past four weeks 72 percent snap 69
62 71 percent and the touches are right
there too 17 19 15 last week 20 big ones
as well Lions 32nd ranked scoring
defense 30th in PPR points per game
allowed to running backs only the bills
are also implied to score more points
then this Dolphins offense this week so
pretty simple Raheem mostert he's
getting 15 to 20 touches per game he's
in an offense implied to score a lot of
points he's facing a terrible defense
you guys know where I'm going with this
we are starting Rahim Moser this week
giving him ahead of Daryl Henderson
Arizona Harris Gus Edwards all that and
so much more so hope you guys enjoyed
that start sit section and now let's
jump into personalized fantasy advice
presented by State Farm where the
personal price plan is all about
creating a price just for you from oh no
thoughts on Alan Robinson Allen Robinson
has less targets than Bennett scrounek
this year that's right Allen Robinson
fourth on his own team third in his own
position room and targets not great he
will get some touchdowns here but I want
to see this Rams offense not be a bottom
five scoring offense before we go back
to the well with a Rob from kpat 12 one
player every fantasy manager should
Target right now I would go ahead and
say
dearest Johnson go ahead and get him
before either him or Kareem Hunter
traded the Browns know they have three
very good running backs and the thing
with the Ernest Johnson if Kareem hunt
gets traded all of a sudden I know I
don't think Johnson's someone that
you're throwing in the flex and feeling
good about a standalone value just one
injury to Nick Chubb though away from
being on the cover of every single wafer
wire article don't don't forget guys
last year three separate occasions where
we saw his Browns offense lean on the
earnest he responded with three top 12
finishes or maybe he's the one that gets
traded to the Rams and gets that role
for himself either way that's the guy
that should be available in almost every
single league and I think this time next
week A lot of people are gonna be
wishing they already had him on their
bench
from sniper unleash Kirk or McLaurin I
am going to be leaning just slightly
towards I Believe Christian Kirk uh this
week it is a tough matchup he is going
to be a little bit safer from the
friendly confines of the slot though
that's the thing when we have amazing
Corners like Patrick's uh certain II we
got to remember a lot of these awesome
outside corners SAS Gardener uh included
for you Jacoby Myers fantasy managers
out there they just don't spend much
time in the slot they stick the outside
maybe they go left to right but they
don't go in the slot so guys like
Christian Kirk like Jacoby Myers like
even Amman Ross St Brown uh yeah all
these guys are free usually from the top
outside corner that's why we see them be
just so PPR friendly more years than not
from Italiano Gus hoverboard James
Connor at Flex Hubbard and Connor are
both banged up right now so cautiously
you know check those things if Conor
plays I am going to go back to him he
was having a Workhorse role for this
Cardinals team before he got hurt he's
had an extra long time to get healthy
they played on Thursday last week he was
already a game time decision there I do
think James Conner one healthy should be
stored in Far More lineups than not
from teamless DJ Moore or Michael
Pittman still going with Michael Pittman
one more week I think they're going to
Central most of their passing attack
around him they should Central most of
their passing attack around him we're
gonna give Sam Ellinger at least one
week here to show that you know the
Colts aren't idiots for benching Matt
Ryan for him from our effort uh
Henderson or Tyler algier definitely
Daryl Henderson the only problem with
algier is that Caleb Huntley and even
Avery Williams are still eating in this
offense Marcus mariota's dual threat
ways doesn't do that many favors but
guess what guys one more week until our
King himself Cordero Patterson is
eligible to come back from IR he's shown
a lot of videos of him sprinting return
is near so Tyler algier managers I think
this might be your last week to even
have a question like this from masonry's
uh Jacoby Myers or pick up Duvernay to
replace Chase
uh Mike I think every team's confused
bro do you ever know is on the Ravens if
we see Bateman ends up getting ruled out
then go ahead with Duvernay but now give
me Jacoby Myers man I actually looked at
his last I think nine games with Matt
Jones under Center he's averaging nine
targets per game this guy is a PPR
godsend we've already had Bill Belichick
commit to Mac Jones over Bailey zappy
who is doing a little bit more checking
down not being quite as aggressive as
Mac Jones out there so give me Jacoby
Myers this week and honestly I'd start
him overdue Renee even if Rashad bavin
ends up being out I mentioned before
they really do get free from these
outside corners so sauce Gardner you
know I can't say enough good things
about what he's done this year if you
want to call him Defensive Rookie of the
Year that's fine I believe he's played
11 total snaps in the slot which Kobe
Myers spends the overall majority of his
time
from Charles Village at Miles Sanders or
Travis etm Travis etn rb1 season is upon
us guys it's so great he already got the
Workhorse roll last week and it's not a
one-week blip on the radar they
literally traded James Robinson out of
here so one of only four running backs
averaging over six yards per carry start
Travis etn every single week moving
forward even if there's a fire and
finally from P Kelly Devonte Smith or
Michael Pittman once again I'm going
back to well with Michael Pittman the
only problem with Devonte Smith low-key
this Eagles passing him hasn't been
doing much over the past three four
weeks still scoring points but this is
the fifth most run heavy offense in the
NFL so one of AJ Brown Devonte Smith and
Dallas Goddard are probably going to dud
more weeks than not at least with
Michael Pittman even if the passing game
even if the offensive environment isn't
that nearly as good as Philly I'm more
confident in him working his way to 810
targets more consistently than I am
Devonte Smith so I want to thank you
guys again for tuning in to be our
fantasy we're back here each and every
Thursday at five o'clock always got you
know a new topic for you guys plenty of
start sick questions as well so go enjoy
this game tonight Brandi Lamar Jackson
Thursday Night Football what more could
we ask for so thanks again for tuning in
I'm Ian Hardison until next time take
care everybody
[Music]